for decades
people have been imagining what it means
for a machine to develop intelligence
a machine with many of the
characteristics of the human mind
this is not tomorrow's dream it is
equipment ready and available for use
today
if humans can use information to solve
problems
then maybe our technology can too
the term artificial intelligence
originally popped up in the 1950s
today ai is everywhere you look
it's targeting ads it's influencing
elections
it isn't just in the news it's how you
get your news
but as different ai technologies become
more and more
integrated into our daily lives should
we be worried about robots taking over
the planet
what are the key challenges facing
society today
and how do we find creative solutions to
tackle those challenges
[Music]
we sat down with some of canada's
leading researchers and policy experts
to ask them what we need to know about
ai these people are looking at the
impacts of ai on society
exploring everything from applications
in the operating room to autonomous cars
to bots writing news articles so they're
pretty used to the hype
i sometimes talk with a taxi driver and
i say oh i work in the eye and they're
like oh and terminator is the first
thing they think
which is a bit unfortunate because we're
definitely extremely far from anything
related to terminator
i think a lot of people think that ai is
this big thing that they cannot
understand
because of that they they are stuck in
the non-understanding part
in the old days when i brought up
artificial intelligence or that i worked
in artificial intelligence to other
people they usually ask
to see the robots the expected robots to
be there but ai has been
catching on a lot recently so they have
people have a better understanding of
the kinds of things that we do
people are asking about how do you how
do you handle bias in the data
how do you make sure that the technology
is safe before you put it into practice
so we're having much more kind of
advanced conversations around artificial
intelligence than ever before
all right so let's jump in
there are a ton of terms floating around
in the realm of ai
ai itself describes both the field of
research
and the capabilities of computer systems
maybe you have a coffee machine instead
of having to
do all of the individual steps to make a
coffee
the machine itself might boil the water
and force it through the beans
and then pour that into your cup those
are all individual things that you could
have done
but instead an algorithm and some
processes work together
and now you have a cup of coffee you can
extend that to
many other human processes
when you ask the average person how
often do you use ai technology and
the majority of them will say rarely or
never because they think of robots
but how many of us have smartphones you
use ai
when you use pretty much any application
there's sort of two big
categories of the way we think about ai
in the broadest sense
one is called narrow ai
that is artificial intelligence that is
developed to do
one specific task the other big category
is what's called artificial general
intelligence
and the idea behind this is that it's
something that
can kind of learn anything it's like a
person
and that is by most people's guesses a
very very long way away
right now we can train computer systems
to complete a task
and just like humans they do this by
learning from experience and improving
themselves along the way
when people refer to ai these days
they're usually talking about this
learning process
called machine learning machine learning
is how to program a computer
to learn from experience instead of
programming the computer to solve a task
directly you will program a computer to
give examples
the algorithm will learn how to solve
the task ah
yes the algorithm you probably hear that
word a lot these days
an algorithm is a set of instructions
that computer software follows to
complete a task
think of it like a recipe for a cake it
tells you step by step what you need to
do
with older systems people had to come up
with the recipe themselves
writing out each line of code to tell
the machine which ingredients and
quantities
to use but machine learning is different
instead of giving the system the recipe
we give it a lot of
examples of cake and program it to come
up with the recipe by itself
it continuously tests out different
combinations improving itself again and
again
as it tries to create the recipe that's
as close as possible to the one we want
you may have heard of another term that
goes one step further
a subfield of machine learning called
deep learning
in deep learning the system learns from
all of the previous recipes it knows
in order to predict a totally new recipe
it uses complex multi-layered structures
called neural networks this is
effectively very abstractly simulated
brains
so large networks of interconnected
units not
unlike the large networks of
interconnected cells that exist in our
brains
deep learning is how systems can
recognize multiple patterns in very
large data sets
it's used to develop things like natural
language processing
which is how computers understand human
language
this allows us to do things like
translate an entire page of text
in one instant it's also used for image
recognition
which is how your phone can recognize
that's you in that selfie
but none of this is possible without one
key element that all machine learning
relies on
data data is very important
the reason that we've seen the advances
that we have
across many application areas of machine
learning is because we
now have enough data and enough compute
we're now
finally at a place where we have enough
examples that we can
train the models robustly when training
computer systems
you can switch up the type and amount of
data you give your model
depending on how you want it to learn
there are several different techniques
or styles of learning
a popular one is reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning it's a subfield
of machine learning where
your algorithm it learns to do a task by
interacting with an environment
data allows machines to identify what
objects are
but even more importantly what they are
not
when humans are learning what it means
to be a dog
they can see millions of examples
of an individual dog walking around
different angles different lighting
a model only has what you give it unless
you deploy it in the wild
and so when we're training a visual
model for example
we have to give it as many examples of a
dog as we can
and importantly we have to give it a lot
of examples of not a dog
this cat is not a dog this cat from this
angle is not a dog this table is not a
dog this chair is not a dog
as we continue to provide more data our
systems will only become more
intelligent for those of us who aren't
spending our days training machines
we might not need to know the math
behind the models but as algorithms
become deeply integrated into our lives
we'll need to start considering the
impacts on both individuals
and society it will have direct impact
in your life very soon or it's already
having an impact
so i think it's good as a critical
minded citizen to be aware
of how things work the same way it's
good to be aware of climate change
ai isn't scary and it doesn't have to be
technical
you don't have to understand the
algorithms or the mathematics behind ai
you just need to understand what it's
used for
you